What does Quran actually mean?
The word Quran is derived from the
Arabic word qara'a
which means to read
or to recite.
And Quran
means
the recitation
or the reading.
The Quran is the last and final
revelation
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala which was
revealed to the last and final messenger
Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has sent
down several revelations. Allah says in
Surah Ra'd, chapter number 13, verse
number 38,
In every age have we sent down
revelation. There were many. By name,
four are mentioned in the Quran. Torah,
Zabur, Injil, and the Quran.
Torah is the wahy, the revelation
which was given to Moses, peace be upon
him.
Zabur is the wahy, the revelation which
was revealed to Prophet David, peace be
upon him.
And Injil is the wahy, the revelation
which was revealed to Prophet Jesus,
peace be upon him. And Quran is the last
and final revelation which was given to
the last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him. So, if
there's something like the Old Testament
and the New Testament, then Quran is the
last testament.
So, Quran actually is a wahy. It is a
revelation.
Normally, people think that Quran is the
book.
Actually, the book Quran, the right
Arabic word is mushaf.
So, Quran
is actually a revelation
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala which was
given to the last and final messenger
Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him.